Eric Boss here with another new
rockstars hot take HBO is the last of us
has made a few key changes from the
games but a big one was having an
outbreak day take place on September
2003 instead of 2013 in the games this
allows the series to touch on some
interesting history from 2003 including
the war on terror which episode 4
references with a few newspapers
referencing the U.S invasion of Iraq and
Colin Powell it makes for an interesting
reflection of a character like Kathleen
who Grieves fedra having beaten her
brother to death but is now using that
tragedy to justify doing so many
horrible things to other people you
could see a parallel with the way
America after being attacked on 911 used
that tragedy to justify invading Iraq
even though it later came out that Iraq
really had nothing to do with 9 11. look
at you Craig Mason taking some shots at
those old political debates from the
early 2000s that we all moved on from it
seems like because everything got so so
much worse in this country